the Joe Rogan experience awesome yeah it
was worth a dollar a year s dude great
for best dude he's been doing on stage
lately I hate to my story thought I show
too recently that the same thing just
talking about the good old days a
[ __ ] drug addiction you want to get
down he describes the city that you're
like oh my god I want to be there what
year what first time in the city I went
I left on what there's six years Oh
first time I've ever been there yeah oh
did you see Times Square when it was
time square yeah yeah yeah but I was
like what's a woman wearing a bra what
they did in Times Square they turned
Times Square into like no Disney Mall it
is discuss it's New York's version of
like of like Disneyland yeah it's
disgusting
yeah and it's a nightmare whenever
you're visiting and also you know like
when you're visiting you're in a car no
need to go to this and all sudden you
look up and you're like are we in
[ __ ] time school like you're just
driving through it I'm like you gotta
get out of here man right like the weird
chaos the bit it's just like it's too
commercialized oh no reason
it feels like you're yeah everything
that makes New York amazing is like gone
gonnigan you joke about if you go for a
meeting and then like you're walking and
people just looking up and he's like why
forget honey that's fine yeah well it's
like it's it's very Vegas esque it's
like walking down the strip yes it is
it's like what are the lights and then
it's all Cano there's no M&Ms
that's not where is invented so why is
it a giant M&M store and when you knew
used to know what it was like with like
peep shows and xxx everywhere and those
it was seedy and weird yeah yeah but
ever dangerous
yeah it was dangerous like legitimately
dangerous I mean the worst time what 70s
80s right I was like the worst crime
time late 70s into the to the mid to
late 80s I was hanging out in New York
in the 80s when I was that was my pool
hustling days and I was doing a lot of
gigs I guess it wasn't the 80s it was
the 90s the early 90s cause if I 91 was
I think the first time I were performed
in New York 91 or maybe 9 a.m. really
yeah oh this is like you're just
starting out though kind of hey you got
am sam billiards oh yes was it what was
Chelsea Chelsea billiards Chelsea losers
we would go to Amsterdam but am stems on
the west side back then it was on a move
that's why I was called am stamping
cents he was on the west side it was an
awesome place I'm sorry that's where I
became friends with dama rera played
pool with him in 94 at Amsterdam
billiards I didn't know he played like
when I went meet a pool player I got
comic will actually plays yeah Dom could
play he called me today I can't wait I
love him so much but uh New York was a
different place man I was around a lot
of these like weirdo homeless grifter
type characters move a lot of dudes we
get arrested for doing three-card Monte
at the pool hall it was like the best
education of like street culture like
people who live on the street I mean
look at home baby people are basically
homeless like sometimes it's to here
they're like my friend Johnny was always
like staying in people say stayed in my
house for sometimes he would stay in
these weird little hostels and flop
houses in New York and places that
didn't have a roof like you have walls
but there would be like no room
everybody here I remember like me as a
kid in that era the perception that you
had of New York is like this is nothing
but crime right they dangerous you're
not alone Wow
Giuliani you know clamped down on all
that [ __ ] I remember when I moved and I
found a place and came back to get my
stuff and I told Neal Brennan I was like
I don't think they have bars in my back
window do I need that it goes I'll do
read the crime stats that's it's a
different City though it's just not that
city anymore 97 it was I mean I don't
remember any crime was although I did
get taken the three-card Monte a number
of times to put money to hell arias dude
I so that and they used to have this
game where they had a nail and a piece
of board and you had a hammer and you
had three shots to get the nail in that
they have that in Thailand dude I did
over every [ __ ] time so hard there was
so many so hoarseness there's so many
hustlers right back in those days in New
York yeah all many people trying to get
off some kind of scam yeah oh yes I've
been scammed by a driver in New York how
what it's like this was not even that
long ago I mean it's probably like seven
eight years where no like you get in the
cab and you're like you know if you
don't live there but you kind of know
like the layout you just like basically
I want to go up
you know 20 blocks this way right and
the guy just goes across town starts
going up like the opposite highway where
we where I'm like which what are we
doing exactly this already does you
could track yourself on your phone yeah
I'm just looking at it like what are we
doing he's like going up to the I go
couldn't you have just gone up that
Avenue that we were on he was like I
don't know what's going on man this is
[ __ ] outrageous
and then we pull up I see like the meter
going going I'm like this is crazy that
was supposed to be a 10-minute Drive and
it's taken 40 minutes he goes just penny
what you ever you want to pay me what
yeah and I go cuz he didn't want to get
caught yeah and I go just say that so I
go like the thing said like $68 and I
was like here's 20 bucks
he's a des it okay you said worried more
paced but weren't they so I'll see you
man yeah I bet it was he he was totally
with it yeah because he described me yes
yeah yeah I said Ezra wants to Jerusalem
when I got there I took uh I was like
take me to be a rock and it was I didn't
realize I was three blocks over he could
you just told me that go that's right
there dude took me around the city and
then let me um I know I don't want to go
home afterwards look what I found out on
my way on that cab ride because I
started texting people at the next place
I was like I was just leaving here and
I'm going to see you should I be on the
[ __ ] port and they're like no so you
didn't speak Spanish in that moment he
was a Nazi I was taken I would have
taken I would have gone right to Spanish
gone to a language that makes me feel
powerful
Nigerian I got pocketed in Florence and
I went into Russian everything every
word I knew in Russian may yell at the
guy and he ran because he was that girl
he's like Russians are [ __ ] animals
she yelled out America a [ __ ] traitor
she do that America and take your
[ __ ] shirt off and said I'm the
machine and started running after a
trouble the [ __ ] one scared more
scared of you than you
write that down
you should write that down you should
write that whole thing down about you
talking about on the radio that's
hilarious
and I don't know why not onstage then
because the audience is gonna be like so
wait what do you do then you pull out
coke and you do a bun and then you start
making no sense and then blood comes out
of your nose it's an awesome show yeah
you could do methane you want if you
don't want to do the coke that night you
take your high blood pressure medication
on stage how that are out